hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2008 chinese science fiction and drama
movie called cj7
the movie begins with a poor
nine-year-old boy named dicky who
somehow manages to attend a fancy
private school in hong kong as soon as
dickie arrives at school he is
approached by ms ewan the only teacher
who cares for dickie he reveals to her
that his mother has passed away and his
father is a very busy person that's why
no one takes care of him
dickie is often bullied by his
classmates especially naughty boy johnny
whose hobby is to mock poor or weak
students
one of the teachers doesn't even want to
get close to him as the boy is always
covered with dirt
he scolds the boy when dickie attempts
to help the teacher pick up his pen on
the floor
after school johnny shows off his new
toy cj-1 which he claims is a very
limited edition robot
the cocky boy and his friends even dare
to make fun of the biggest girl in the
school during the pe class dickie gets
punished alongside the girl since both
of them don't have proper shoes for
sport
it seems like the girl has a crush on
dickie the scene then moves to a
construction worker who turns out to be
dicky's father ciao t
he works hard to earn money every day so
that he can keep sending his son to that
expensive school
later that night chao returns to his
house which turns out to be a partially
demolished house he brings his son an
old electric fan as a surprise but
unfortunately it doesn't work at all
since it was taken from a junkyard
despite being a poor family chao always
teaches his son to be a decent guy
telling him not to steal or take
something that doesn't belong to them
the next day while dickie is watching
cartoons from a store's tv suddenly a
breaking news shows up
the interviewee on the tv claims that an
unidentified flying object has just
flown over him in crashes
afterward dickie goes to a toy store
where he begs his father to buy the same
toy as johnny cj1 but chow tells him to
put it back as he cannot afford it the
boy insists so chow has to beat his son
up in front of other customers the upset
dickie runs away and coincidentally
comes across ms yuen who is passing by
she asks the father whether it is
possible for her to visit their house
but chao politely declines the request
that night he returns to the junkyard to
find new shoes for dickie where he
doesn't realize that a huge ufo is
flying away in front of him
he finds a green orb left by the alien
and brings it home to cheer up her son
at school dickie immediately shows his
new melon toy to his crush fanny who is
not amazed at all
not long after johnny and the boys
confront dickie he claims that the melon
toy is much better than cj1 thus he
decides to name it cj7 offended with a
statement johnny summons a huge boy who
tosses him away effortlessly
the following night the melon toy
suddenly starts moving which makes
dickie terrified and throws it away
assuming it is a ghost he freaks out and
cannot stop screaming causing his dad to
get angry and lock him in a wardrobe the
melon toy magically emits a very bright
light turning the wardrobe into a space
view while transforming into a cute
alien creature
dickey befriends the alien which he
calls cj7 from now on
while having fun with the alien he
discovers that cj7 has the ability to
restore the rotten apple the following
day dickey tests out cj7 power by
forcing it to fight with a fierce dog
which gets defeated easily by the alien
upon arriving at school cj7 fabricates
advanced cool sunglasses with micro
flying cameras which allows dickie to
copy other classmates answers
johnny is distracted by the cameras and
accidentally hits the teacher with a
ruler
soon after the test result is announced
and for the first time in his life
dickie gets 100 which shocks the entire
class
cj7 also creates a pair of boots for
dickie which allows him to surpass his
pe teacher's personal record in high
jump sport the boots also make dicky
excel in several sports including
swimming and football
since dickie has caused a lot of mess in
the school the teachers call the police
to arrest him but he uses the shoes to
fly high towards the sky where he spots
a cloud forming as cj7 he falls down and
suddenly wakes up from the dream
however cj7 is real and he is optimistic
that he will also excel in real life
with cj seven's help which makes his dad
confused
cj7 rebattles the fierce dog in real
life but this time cj7 is powerless and
both of them get beaten up badly by it
at school dickie demands cj7 to create
the same glasses as the one he used in
his dream but it seems like the alien
doesn't understand him and gives him a
poop instead
at the exam dickie is clueless because
he didn't study the night earlier after
class he expresses his disappointment
towards the alien by drowning it in the
toilet the boy then desperately orders
cj7 to give him the magic boots for pe
class but cj7 fires poop projectiles
towards him for revenge
during the pe class he gets sprayed by
the gardeners as his body and uniform is
full of dirt while the entire class
laughs at him to make things worse the
teacher scolds him saying he is a
disgrace for the fancy school
after school dickie lures the terrified
cj-7 from the tree while saying some
sweet words to calm him down
however as soon as it shows up he
captures the alien with a plastic bag
and immediately throws him to a trash
bin
he blames cj7 for the embarrassment he
received earlier but later he realizes
that he has made a mistake and runs back
to save him from the bin
however he finds that the trash bin has
been emptied by a garbage truck he
attempts to chase the truck but it is
already too far
dicky returns home and feels remorse for
throwing cj7 away but when he discovers
that the alien comes back to the house
he immediately runs to it and apologizes
telling it how much he misses the alien
chow is confused after he finds out that
his son and cj-7 know each other
dickie admits that cj7 is a high-tech
toy and was given to him by one of his
friends at school
the curious chow squeezes the toy and is
amazed with its flexibility while cj
seven rides and squeals in pain
after that dickey confesses that he was
lying saying that the toy was from the
melon toy chow gave earlier to him
still that evening cj7 is concerned with
dickie and chow's poor situation so it
gets up and attempts to fix the broken
electric fan with its magic
its antenna emits some kind of electric
waves which restores the broken cables
the electric fan is working again but it
seems like the repairing process has
drained most of cj7 energy as the
antenna becomes red
next morning dickie brings cj7 who looks
tired and exhausted to school again
upon arrival johnny and the gang spot
cj7 in his backpack and forcibly take it
out of it
cj7 attempts to run away from the boys
but gets caught by johnny at the end the
bullies try to examine it with sharp
tools but cj7 is just too elastic to be
cut off dickie breaks free and attacks
johnny but he summons the big guy again
thanks to dicky's kindness the giant
girl shows up and the duel between two
giant students begins
the girl eventually wins the battle and
all of them are being punished for
causing chaos
the teacher demands them to tell him
what was happening but none of them
responds to him when the teacher walks
away cj7 appears from the bushes
the boys interact with it and are
fascinated with its ability to perform
facial expressions of what they are
saying
dickie then thanks johnny for not
reporting about the alien to the teacher
meanwhile the giant students reconcile
the scene moves to the construction site
where he shows off to his co-workers
that his son got 100 in a test
the boss grabs the paper and turns out
that dickie actually got zero but he
added 10 before the zero to make it look
like 100. the boss accuses his son as a
cheater which enrages chao
he attempts to hit the boss but gets
beaten up by him instead
the boss also fires him from the job for
attempting to rebel
chao returns home angrily and confronts
dickie the father is disappointed with
his son's attitude and decides to take
cj7 away from him saying that he has to
work hard if he wants to play again
chao challenges dickie to get over 60 in
an exam and if he does he will leave him
alone
the following day chao arrives at the
school to deliver a lunch box to dickie
he meets ms ewan who offers herself to
come to their house to help dicky study
for the upcoming exam
before leaving chao expresses his
gratitude towards the caring teacher
long story short dickie fulfills his
promise with his father by getting 65 in
the recent exam
the father returns to the construction
site and apologizes to his boss the boss
also admits his mistake and accepts chao
back as a sight worker while giving him
a bonus salary
while working chao forgets to attach his
safety belt and one of the gas cylinders
falls off the building its rope traps
chow's leg causing him to fall down with
the gas cylinder
he manages to hold on for a moment until
the mesh netting he's holding his torn
apart and he finally free-falls to the
ground
dickie is informed about the accident
and immediately heads over to the
hospital but unfortunately the father
passes away in the hospital
mizuan brings dickie back to the house
where she informs him that the father
has passed away
the boy bursts into tears and pushes the
teacher out of the house
he keeps crying hoping that his father
will come back the following morning
meanwhile at the hospital cj seven comes
out from the bag and feels sad when it
sees chow's dead body
the alien uses its remaining energy to
resurrect chao
in the morning dickie wakes up finding
his father sleeping next to him like
nothing has happened
he immediately hugs him in tears and
promises him that he will be a good son
from now on they then find powerless and
exhausted cj-7 inside the bag a few
moments later the orb detaches from its
antenna and gradually disappears while
cj-7 suddenly transforms into a doll
form with crossed eyes
assuming that it's out of battery chau
attempts to use electric shocks and
inject liquid toward the alien but
nothing works
chao and dickie mourn but since then
dickie becomes more motivated to study
harder
the new term starts soon and everything
goes back to normal the giant boy falls
in love with a giant girl while chow
also develops more serious relationship
with miz yuan
dickie wears a cj-7 doll as a necklace
hoping that it will come back to life
someday at the end of the movie the ufo
returns to earth and dickie is surprised
when a horde of cj-7 with various colors
comes out running towards him
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching